Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Que diriez-vous
si toutes et tous ensemble,
nous avions le pouvoir de diviser par
trois le nombre des morts sur les routes,
de diviser par dix le nombre
des viols et des agressions sexuelles,
de faire en sorte qu’il n’y ait
quasiment plus de vols avec violences
ou de cambriolages.
De sauver la vie de la quasi-totalité
des victimes de meurtres.
Si je vous disais que
toutes et tous ensemble,
nous avons le pouvoir de faire en sorte
que plus personne n’ait peur
de marcher seul dans la rue,
de laisser ses enfants jouer dehors,
ou encore de se faire cambrioler
pendant les vacances.
En un mot, si je vous disais
que nous avons toutes et tous
le pouvoir de faire en sorte
que l’insécurité
ne soit plus un problème ?
Et maintenant, si je vous disais qu’en
plus, nous avons toutes et tous le pouvoir
de faire économiser à l’État
et à la société,
chaque année,
des dizaines de milliards d’euros ?
Vous allez me dire que
c’est trop beau pour être vrai,
que je suis en train de rêver.
Eh bien, vous vous trompez.
La moitié de l’humanité détient
et utilise déjà ce super-pouvoir.
Mais avant de vous révéler
en quoi il consiste,
je tiens à dire que, malheureusement, il
ne va pas plaire à certains d’entre vous.
Aussi, je vous demande de surpasser
le sentiment d’offense
que vous pourriez ressentir
parce qu’il n’a pas lieu d’être
et parce qu’il est une entrave
à notre bonne marche, à toutes et tous,
vers un monde meilleur,
à la fois plus riche et plus apaisé.
Je vais commencer par vous dire
comment j’ai découvert ce super-pouvoir.
Tout est parti d'une anecdote.
Un jour, alors que je marchais
seule dans la rue,
des services de police sont passés
devant moi, toutes sirènes hurlantes.
Bon, ok, jusque-là, rien d’extraordinaire,
mais la pensée qui m’est venue à ce
moment-là était quelque peu singulière.
En effet, je me suis dit
que, très probablement,
ces services de police intervenaient
pour faire face à un délit commis...
par un homme.
Pour être très honnête, cette pensée
ne m’est pas tout à fait venue par hasard.
En effet, je suis Lucile Peytavin,
historienne, spécialiste dans l’histoire
économique et sociale des femmes,
experte dans la prévention des violences.
Ça fait longtemps que je travaille
sur les différences entre les hommes
et les femmes dans la société.
Et c’est à ce titre que,
un jour, je suis tombée
sur une statistique
qui m’a laissée sans voix.
La voici.
Aujourd’hui, en France,
la population carcérale masculine
représente 96,3% du total.
En un mot,
les prisons sont remplies d’hommes.
Lorsque j’ai découvert cela,
je me suis demandé :
« Qu’est-ce que cela dit
de la violence dans notre société ?
Et qu’est-ce que ça veut dire du rapport
entre les hommes et la violence ? »
Alors j’ai creusé et je suis allé chercher
d’autres statistiques
qui sont produites par les ministères
de la Justice et de l’Intérieur.
Les voici.
Aujourd’hui, les hommes représentent 83%
des mises en cause par la justice,
90% des personnes
condamnées par la justice.
Ils sont surreprésentés
dans tous les types d’infractions,
et notamment les plus graves.
99% des auteurs de viol,
97% des auteurs d’agressions sexuelles,
86% des auteurs d’homicides, 84% des
auteurs d’accidents mortels sur la route,
95% des auteurs de vols avec violence,
91% des auteurs de cambriolages.
Et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Et ce qui est dingue, c’est que
cette surreprésentation des hommes
dans la délinquance et la criminalité
n’est presque jamais questionnée
par notre société.
Nous l’expliquons par l’âge des auteurs
en visant la jeunesse,
nous l’expliquons
par l’origine des auteurs,
en ciblant les immigrés, les étrangers,
nous l’expliquons
par des troubles mentaux,
en parlant de fous, de déséquilibrés,
de chauffards,
mais nous ne l’expliquons pas
par le premier critère qui définit le
profil des délinquants et des criminels,
à savoir le sexe masculin.
Bien sûr, cela ne veut pas dire que tous
les hommes sont délinquants et criminels.
Mais cela veut dire que l'immense majorité
des délinquants et des criminels
sont des hommes.
Et cela est vrai quelle que soit la
tranche d’âge, la zone géographique,
le milieu social, le niveau d'éducation.
Prenons par exemple le niveau de vie.
Parce qu’en effet, il n’est pas rare
d’expliquer la délinquance
par la pauvreté.
Mais les femmes aussi vivent dans la
pauvreté, et même plus que les hommes,
si on tient compte des écarts de taux
d’emploi et de salaires par exemple.
Eh bien, dans cette même situation,
les femmes commettent peu ou pas
de faits de délinquance
ou de criminalité comparée
à leurs homologues masculins.
Une fois que j’ai eu tout cela en tête,
une question s’est imposée à moi.
Combien paient chaque année
l’État et la société
pour faire face à ces délits
commis par les hommes ?
Quel est le surcoût qu’ils entraînent
comparé aux délits et à la criminalité
commis par les femmes ?
En d’autres termes,
combien la France économiserait
si les hommes se comportaient
comme les femmes,
s’ils commettaient aussi peu de faits de
délinquance et de criminalité qu’elles ?
Parce que oui, aujourd'hui, les
ministères de la Justice et de l'Intérieur
fonctionnent en grande
majorité pour les hommes.
Nous déployons des moyens humains,
matériels, financiers,
absolument colossaux.
Nous investissons dans des services
de police, de justice, de santé.
Les citoyens et les citoyennes
paient aussi un prix
parce qu’il y a des victimes,
des souffrances physiques, psychologiques,
des pertes de productivité,
des destructions de biens.
Aussi, il y a trois ans, je me suis lancée
dans le calcul de ce surcoût.
Et je suis arrivée à une estimation
à près de 100 milliardsd’euros par an.
Sachant que le budget global
de la France atteint aujourd’hui
près de 400 milliardsd'euros par an.
Et ce surcoût,
je l’ai appelé « le coût de la virilité ».
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ce ne sont pas les hommes en
tant que tels qui en sont responsables,
mais l’éducation qu’ils reçoivent,
leur transmettant des valeurs viriles,
les poussant à adopter
ces comportements asociaux.
Parce que non, contrairement
aux idées reçues qui circulent encore,
il n’y a rien dans la biologie,
dans la physiologie des hommes,
qui les pousserait
à se comporter de cette façon.
Prenons par exemple
la testostérone, au hasard.
Oui, en effet, on explique bien souvent la
violence des hommes par la testostérone.
Mais des études récentes
sur le sujet indiquent
que cette hormone chez un même individu
peut être aussi bien liée
à des comportements agressifs
qu’à des comportements altruistes.
Donc non, la testostérone
n’est pas à l’origine
de la surreprésentation des hommes
dans la délinquance et la criminalité.
Alors comment expliquer
cette surreprésentation ?
Eh bien, sur ce point, les sciences
de l’éducation, la sociologie,
nous apportent des réponses.
Elles nous indiquent qu’il y a
une véritable acculturation
des garçons et des hommes à la violence,
au non-respect des règles,
dès les premiers jours de leur vie.
La principale notion néfaste
au cœur de cette acculturation,
au cœur de cette éducation,
est la virilité.
Alors qu’est-ce que la virilité ?
Selon Olivia Gazalé, qui est spécialiste
du sujet, qui est philosophe,
la virilité est une norme
qui définit dans notre société
ce que doit être un vrai homme.
C’est une notion qui rassemble
les attributs de force, de puissance,
à la fois physiques et moraux,
et qui s’exprime
par des comportements de domination,
et donc de violence,
de discrimination, de rejet, de haine,
de non-respect des règles
au détriment de l’ensemble de la société,
des femmes, mais des hommes eux-mêmes.
Et le problème, c’est que nous éduquons
encore aujourd’hui les garçons
à travers cette valeur de virilité.
Que cela soit fait consciemment
ou inconsciemment.
Parce que, en effet, nous-mêmes, nous
avons été éduqués à travers ces schémas
et on les transmet
sans toujours nous en rendre compte.
Mais les expériences de sociologie qui ont
été faites sur le sujet montrent
que le processus se met en place dès
les premiers jours de la vie des garçons.
Par exemple, nous les parents,
les adultes, la famille, l’entourage,
nous avons des contacts physiques beaucoup
plus toniques avec les bébés garçons.
Nous valorisons beaucoup
plus leur force physique,
nous verbalisons beaucoup moins
les sentiments avec eux.
Par contre, nous valorisons la colère.
Par exemple, lorsqu’on lit
une histoire à un petit garçon,
on surjoue beaucoup plus la colère que
lorsqu’on la lit à une petite fille.
Et enfin, nous sommes plus permissifs :
les petits garçons sont plus libres
d’avoir des comportements perturbants,
ils sont moins prévenus du danger.
Il y a la violence aussi, qui s’exprime
très rapidement dans les jeux des garçons,
avec les jeux de bagarre, de bataille,
les jeux avec les armes factices.
Il faut savoir que, aujourd’hui encore,
dans les catalogues de jeux,
dans 92% des cas, lorsqu’il y a une arme,
elle est tenue par un petit garçon.
Et d’ailleurs, comment pouvons-nous
accepter sans le remettre en question,
que des jouets puissent
avoir la forme d’une arme ?
Question.
Et donc in fine, en coupant
les petits garçons de leur sensibilité,
de leurs émotions, en les poussant
à être forts, à être vigoureux,
à ne pas respecter les règles,
nous les adultes, nous créons un terrain
favorable aux futures conduites déviantes.
Mais bien sûr, nous ne sommes pas seuls.
Il y a par exemple la culture
qui joue un rôle déterminant dans
la transmission de cette éducation virile.
Aujourd’hui encore,
dans les livres ou dans les films,
l’immense majorité des héros
sont des garçons, sont des hommes,
qui s’adonnent à une violence
qui est bien souvent légitimée,
ne serait-ce que pour sauver le monde.
Et cela a un impact direct sur les garçons
qui s’identifient à ces personnages
et qui développent
une appétence pour cette violence.
Il y a aussi le moment de l’adolescence
qui est un moment de cristallisation
dans la construction de l’identité virile,
qui se passe entre pairs,
c’est-à-dire entre garçons.
Et donc, pour montrer qu’ils sont forts,
moralement, physiquement,
les garçons vont se donner
des coups, vont s’insulter,
et il va falloir qu’ils montrent
qu’ils résistent à cette souffrance.
À ce titre, des sociologues,
tels que David Lebreton,
parlent de véritables rites de passage.
Aussi l’éducation que nous donnons
aux garçons, aux hommes,
tout au long de leur vie,
les pousse à être et à se comporter
en tant que dominants.
Vous allez me dire : « Ok, c’est
peut-être vrai dans les grandes lignes,
mais aujourd’hui les choses changent. »
Ce qui est vrai,
c’est qu’on en parle de plus en plus.
Mais concernant l'éducation des garçons,
les choses évoluent peu.
Par exemple, nous leur transmettons,
de façon toujours systématique,
le mépris du féminin.
C’est-à-dire que nous apprenons
aux petits garçons
qu’être un homme,
c’est surtout ne pas être une femme.
Donc surtout pas de rose,
surtout pas de couettes,
surtout pas de posture trop efféminée.
Quand on les compare aux filles,
c’est pour les humilier -
« Tu pleures comme une fille »,
« Tu cours comme une fille » -
et de ce fait, les petits garçons
intègrent très rapidement
que le féminin est méprisable et que
les femmes sont inférieures aux hommes.
Et il faut avoir bien conscience
que lorsque nous faisons cela,
nous créons in fine
des comportements sexistes et homophobes.
Et ce qui est grave, c’est que,
de cette éducation à la virilité,
nous en sommes tous victimes.
Nous payons toutes et tous
un prix à cette virilité.
Bien sûr, nous les femmes, par les
violences systémiques que nous subissons,
rappelons une réalité
qui devrait tous nous révolter.
Aujourd’hui, en France, une femme
meurt encore tous les 2,5 jours
sous les coups de son compagnon
ou de son ex-compagnon.
Mais les hommes paient aussi
un prix à cette virilité.
Savez-vous que déjà
à l’âge de quatorze ans,
les garçons ont 70% de risques de plus que
les filles de mourir dans un accident ?
Que 78% des morts sur la route
sont des hommes ?
Que l’immense majorité des cas de cancers
liés à des comportements addictifs de
tabac ou d’alcool concerne des hommes ?
Parce que oui, prouver sans cesse qu’on
est fort moralement, physiquement et bien,
ça a un coût sur la santé
et la vie des hommes.
Si bien que si on prend la population
des hommes dans son entièreté,
ils ont 2 à 3 fois
plus de risques que les femmes
de mourir de façon prématurée,
c’est-à-dire avant 65 ans,
d’une mort évitable, c’est-à-dire
liée à un comportement à risque.
Alors, quelle est la solution ?
Quel est ce super-pouvoir que
nous avons toutes et tous en nous ?
Eh bien, ce super-pouvoir,
je l’ai trouvé dans les chiffres.
Parce que les femmes qui représentent
la moitié de la population -
51,6% de la population -
et qui ne sont pas, ou peu, éduquées
à travers ces valeurs viriles,
ont des comportements
beaucoup plus altruistes,
beaucoup plus en adéquation avec
la société de droit dans laquelle on vit.
Elles ne représentent que 17%
des mises en cause par la justice.
Et en effet, les femmes reçoivent
une éducation qui favorise leur empathie,
qui leur permet une meilleure
compréhension, gestion de leurs émotions,
qui leur enseigne un plus grand respect
des règles et d'autrui.
Et donc ce pouvoir,
nous l’avons sous les yeux :
éduquons les garçons comme les filles.
Éduquons les garçons comme les filles.
Permettons-leur aussi
de jouer avec des poupons
pour qu’ils apprennent aussi
à s’occuper d’autrui.
Verbalisons davantage les sentiments
pour qu’ils soient plus empathiques.
Contraignons-les suffisamment
pour qu’ils respectent les règles.
Tout ce que nous faisons déjà
avec les filles, avec les femmes,
et qui a des effets tellement plus
positifs pour l’ensemble de la société.
Et donc grâce à cette
éducation plus humaniste,
nous économiserions a minima
100 milliardsd’euros par an
que nous pourrions investir
dans le système des retraites,
dans les hôpitaux,
dans la recherche, dans la culture,
dans des politiques
tellement plus porteuses
que de construire des palais de justice
et des prisons.
Il y aurait des changements notables
pour les citoyens et les citoyennes,
puisque les niveaux de délinquance et de
criminalité baisseraient drastiquement.
Et donc les viols, les cambriolages, les
agressions ne seraient plus un problème,
l'insécurité ne serait plus un problème.
Et donc oui, grâce à
cette éducation plus humaniste,
vivre dans une société plus riche
et plus apaisée ne serait plus un rêve
mais bien une réalité.
Le poète a toujours raison,
l’économiste confirme :
la femme est bien l’avenir de l’homme.
(Applaudissements)